and welcome back to CBS this morning
we're following breaking news out of
Germany reports there say there's been a
deadly shooting outside a synagogue on
Yom Kippur the holiest day of the year
and on the Jewish calendar police are
telling people to stay home or find a
secure place to go senior foreign
correspondent Mark Phillips is tracking
the story in London mark what do we know
so far
well so far Anthony we know the basic
facts according to police the shooting
took place in Halle which is about 50
miles south of Berlin police were on
heightened alert because of the Yom
Kippur holiday and the shooting appears
to have taken place near a synagogue
according to local media the attack or
attackers it's not clear yet are set to
fired several shots and then fled in a
car police say they have now arrested a
suspect and there are reports of more
gunfire in a town about 10 miles away
they also say they are increasing
security around synagogues and Jewish
cemeteries there has been a rise in
anti-semitic incidents over the past
year in Germany some statistics show an
increase of as much as 60% Gail thank
you very much mark